[Music]
hello there
jun is here once again and with it comes
a bunch of new games vying for your
attention
and cash of course i found a range of
games for all budgets
and the run of finding a free-to-play
game worth your time
continues too so if you're ready here's
eight new games for the month of june
2021
without a doubt the biggest game of the
month is ratchet and clank rift apart
which is another playstation 5 exclusive
this series has been around for almost
20 years now with the original game
dropping back on the ps2 in 2002.
the core gameplay loop remains the same
to this day a third person platformer
with a heavy fixation on the weird and
wonderful guns and gadgets on offer
a new gadget this time around allows
ratchet to use a rift
tether to pull himself through tears in
time and space
instantaneously this is also said to be
the reason why rift apart cannot run on
a ps4
as the game effectively loads multiple
locations that the player could choose
to go to at
any point so the ultra fast ssd is
definitely needed for this one
this time around ratchet and clank have
another person in their squad
a female lombax named rivet the previews
of the game are due out any moment but
from what we've seen so far this game is
looking to showcase the ps5's power
through the ssd
and take advantage of the haptics and
the adaptive triggers in the dual sense
controller
if you're one of the lucky few to find a
ps5 out in the wild then you can play
rift apart from june 11th
let's stick with the ps5 exclusive
content with final fantasy vii
remake integrate the main thing on sale
here is the first expansion of last
year's incredibly successful final
fantasy 7 remake
in this dlc we get our hands on yuffie
another loved character in the story who
this time gets her own episode
the integrated release includes a free
upgrade to ps5 for the ps4 users
who bought the original game that
includes updated visuals a dramatic
increase in load speeds
and the ps5 version will begin to
utilize the dual sense controller too
the frustrating part for ps plus
subscribers is that of the time i'm
writing this
that ps4 version of final fantasy vii
will not be upgraded to the ps5 version
for free
let's hope this changes if not it's just
a tough pill to swallow
from the outside looking in if you liked
final fantasy 7 there's more final
fantasy 7 coming your
way from june the 10th the dlc and the
base game are timed exclusives on
playstation but that will run out soon
so i would expect xbox players to be
part of this party soon enough
[Music]
game three this month is sniper ghost
warrior contracts two
and guess what it's a sniper simulation
game and the best thing of all in these
types of games
are the slo-mo sniper shots across the
map
it's so good if you played the series
before you know the jam here we're
playing as raven again
who is sent all over the world to snipe
people in the face
a typical mission sees us touch down on
enemy soil and slowly find the highest
viewpoint to snipe our targets from
getting to that point though is a huge
part of the game going in stealthy or
pretending you're an 80s action movie
star seems to be the two options most
used
then from your sniper's nest it's time
to locate the target
and take out those bad guys but you must
also take into account the wind
resistance and the bullet drop 2 needs
to be calculated
so it's definitely more of a sim than an
arcade game at times
contracts 2 is at its best when we play
for accidental eliminations
using everyday items to off the bad guys
for us
like dropping a shipping crate on
someone's head lovely
sniper ghost warrior contracts 2
releases on ps4 xbox one
and pc on june the 4th
okie dokie let's look at some free games
and here's one i personally
have been looking forward to because i'm
old super bomberman are
online if you are old school like me
this will be easy to understand but if
you're new to this series
let me break it down super bomberman
pits players against each other in an
arena of sorts
and then gives them bombs to break walls
and blow each other up
under the destroyable walls are numerous
power-ups ranging from the ability to
kick bombs out of the way
to increasing their blast radius from
there it's the last man standing is the
champion
and that's the thing we should
concentrate on here because our online
introduces
battle royale to bomberman all three too
64 players queue up to join a match and
begin in adjoining rooms with three
other players
once a winner is declared that player
can move into another room and join that
battle
this continues and repeats until someone
achieves the victory
and shout to win a winner chicken dinner
a quick note to my discord fam
let's play this this could be lots of
fun if there's custom games
there'll be the usual battle pass style
upgrade path which includes a ton of
cosmetic items to unlock like
changing your bomb into popcorn for
instance
sadly xbox fam you'll need to wait a
little longer for this as
it's scheduled for ps4 switch and pc
oh and the release date is may 27th
depending on when you're watching this
it's already out let's play
another free game i discovered this
month is mega zombie
from watching the beta footage i'm
getting roblox vibes
the premise is simple mega zombie is a
free-to-play third-person shooter game
in which 16 players fight it out in
teams but there's a twist
there's zombies here too the art style
is different to say the least and this
is definitely a low budget game but from
the videos i watched last night on this
it could be something special whether it
has the opportunity to grow
i can't say for certain if you want to
play the full game it's technically in
beta right now on playstation 4.
no need to wait until june it's free
right now you can download it and play
right away if you do try it let me know
your thoughts i'm very interested to see
what happens with this one
take a look at this game operation tango
releasing on the first tuesday of the
month june the first on ps4 ps5
xbox consoles and pc operation tango is
a two-person game which
can't be played with any more or any
less it has to be two
it takes two you and your partner in
crime are tasked with beating puzzles
and traps to secure a macguffin
you're essentially secret agents one
character is the agent in the field
passing through the trials and the other
is the skilled hacker pulling the
strings
like the unsung heroes in mission
impossible movies without both parts
working perfectly
this crime caper will be over before you
know it
so grab a mic and a friend you can trust
because games like this will ruin
friendships but it's worth it
crossplay is confirmed and it's been
reported that operation tango
will be in this month's ps plus it's
only a rumor though i'll know more on
wednesday and if that's true i'll update
the description below
in the free titles tuesday june the
first is release day
[Music]
back in 2012 chivalry medieval warfare
released a kind of hack and slash
brutality
depicting the middle ages and all the
melee combat seen in war
now in 2021 it's time to go back as
chivalry 2
arrives on console and pc chivalry 2 is
a 64 player battlefield
that is way more than button bashing the
melee elements take skill and timing
with different thrusts and jabs needed
for different opponents
it's like the logical evolution of
moronna this game is so brutal that your
character will keep fighting
even if they lose a limb updates to the
archery mechanic and crossbows means
that melee isn't your only choice of
action
all you have to do now is pick a side
are you one of the mason order in red
and black
or one of the agatha knights spotting
blue and gold
by the end of the battle everyone is
usually wearing red and in pieces
chivalry 2 hits you in the face with a
hammer on june the 8th on playstation
xbox
and pc
time for one more i think scarlet nexus
an action rpg
our heroes live in a time of psionic
hormones which led to
humanity revealing new abilities like
speaking to each other through
thought and moving objects with our
minds this new era
brought with it deranged mutants who
want to eat our brains
lovely we are tasked with protecting
humanity one more time
scarlet nexus hopes to grab fans of the
near series
with its take on combat and emotional
impact of the characters during the
story's progression the combat in
particular
looks really addictive there's something
about picking up an object with your
mind and throwing it which never gets
old
scarlet nexus releases on playstation
xbox and pc
on june 25th so there we have it eight
new games
to waste your life on in june 2021 do
any of these float your boat
imma definitely get me some ratchet and
clank and i can't wait for bomberman r
online
hopefully i'll see you in battle i'm
adam from playstation grenade i don't
know why i'm still talking
no one's ever here at this point so hi
in fact hi mum
love you bye